je pense que c'est un peu égoïste parce
que je crois que dans la vie d'un couple
il faut au moins un enfant ça donne un
but dans la
vie des pondeuses c'est le mot certes
très choquant qu'avait utilisé une de
nos invités lors d'une des précédentes
émissions pour qualifier les maères de
famille et nous nous souvenons que vous
n'aviez pas tellement apprécié cet
adjectif la coupable elle est avec nous
vous vous en souvenez peut-être c'est
Anne de la Ligue du droit des femmes
vous avez choisi de ne pas être une
pondeuse puisque c'est l'épithète que
vous utilisez vous avez choisi de ne pas
être mère du tout vous avez choisi de ne
pas avoir d'enfants c'est le thème de
l'émission d'aujourd'hui Anne comment
pourquoi avez-vous fait un tel choix et
expliquez-nous brièvement
oui j'ai fait ce choix très très jeune
parce que j'ai pris conscience que ce
n'est pas la maternité qui était un
poids un fait mais c'était les
conditions qui lui étaient faites et
comme je voulais vivre vivre ce qu'on
appelle ma vie
c'est-à-dire m'épanouir de façon diverse
profiter de ma liberté j'avais très bien
compris que le faire tout en ayant des
enfants c'était à peu près impossible
donc j'ai choisi de ne pas avoir
d'enfants parce que je voulais assumer
ma liberté et me réaliser est-ce que
vous avez l'impression que ce choix vous
êtes avez été seul à le faire ou
beaucoup d'autres femmes actuellement
font ce type de choix est-ce que vous
sentez une exception oui avant c'était
plutôt exceptionnel mais je pense que
maintenant de plus en plus de femmes
accèdent à une conscience de du
sacrifice que représente la maternité et
vont faire le même choix que moi oui
compte le faire parmi les adolescents et
je crois qu'on peut dire aussi queelles
ont peut-être maintenant un peu plus les
moyens de faire ce choix c'est-à-dire
c'est grâce à la contraception ou à
l'avortement qu'elles peuvent vraiment
choisir de ne pas avoir d'enfants du
tout Oui entre autres effectivement
elles sont plus libres que qu'avant de
faire ce choix et en même temps elles
sont plus conscientes aussi de ce que ça
représente d'avoir des enfants même
indépendamment de la est-ce que c'est un
choix facile à faire non c'est un choix
très difficile comme tous les choix qui
vont à contrecourant des opinions reçues
c'est un choix définitif absolument pour
moi il est définitif madame Mouté est-ce
que vous voulez vous présenter vous dire
dire vous-même qui vous êtes comment
vous vous situez par rapport au problème
oui moi je rejoins beaucoup les idées de
Anne bien sûr parce que très jeune j'ai
toujours été contre les idées reçues
contre être mis dans un cadre déterm é
et je me souviens fort bien au lycée
quand j'avais 17 ans un jour j'ai eu une
discussion avec une de mes camarades de
classe nous parlions de mariage et elle
disait de toute façon le mariage c'est
uniquement pour avoir des enfants ça
m'avait fait bondir d'ailleurs après ça
n'a plus été ni une amie ni autre parce
que je ne voulais pas que dès le départ
avant même que j'ai pu choisir quoi que
ce soit on me mette l'étiquette de
reproductrice vous êtes marié alors oui
je suis mariée pour la deuxième fois
même et sans enfants et sans enfants et
et je m'enorte très bien oui oui je me
sens tout à fait et heureuse et pas
tourmenté ni manquant de quelque chose
il me semblait lorsque vous cherchiez la
façon de répondre avait un tout petit
peu de résignation non un tout petit peu
de de regret aucun au aucun la question
est vaste et suppose bien bien des
nuances dans la réponse que une femme
peut refuser d'avoir des enfants
elle peut bien sûr mais elle pra un jour
elle le PRA un jour parce qu'on ne va
pas contre la nature
impunément la vie ne ne s'arrête pas à à
la à quelques décennies ni le jour où
vous décidez de avoir ou de ne pas avoir
d'enfant ni le ni pendant les les 20 ans
qui suivent elle se continuera jusqu'à
votre vieillesse et que deviendrez-vous
à ce moment-là c'est un problème de
morale que vous posez je pose un
problème de morale oui et je pose un
problème de bon sens il y a déjà des
réactionspri madame m et bien votre
vieillesse ça c'est tout à fait à chaque
fois le mot qui m'ennuie quand j'entends
les femmes parler ou me dire à moi vous
avez pas d'enfant et qu'est-ce que vous
ferez quand vous serez vieille alors
c'est un placement qu'on fait on met un
enfant au monde pour avoir quelque chose
plus tard sur quoi retomber ça me paraît
d'un égoïsme infini je voudrais euh vous
présenter les réactions de l'homme de la
rue parce qu'il s'agit surtout de
réaction d'homme au choix qu'a fait Anne
et qu'a fait madame Mouté on fait de
nombreuses autres femmes regardons
ensemble ce télécin qui choisit de ne
pas avoir d'enfant du tout
ah moi je trouve ça que c'est pas bien
pourquoi parce que je trouve qu'un
ménage sans enfant c'est pas valable je
pense que c'est un peu égoïste parce que
je crois que dans la vie d'un couple il
faut au moins un enfant ça donne un but
dans la vie je trouve qu'elles ont grand
tort parce que il est naturel pour une
femme d'avoir d'avoir un enfant c'est
tout à fait naturel
elles ont raison personnellement jeen
veux pas et parce que parce que j'estime
qu'il don CR de de sou on a suffisamment
de problèmes pour se pour vivre soi-même
elle a pas envie elle pense à rien elle
a rien dans sa petite
tête diable
a peut-être pas
tort je sais pas je regrette que des
femmes n'en aient pas envie du tout je
regrette pour elle je trouve ça je
trouve ça très mal pourquoi pourquoi
parce que c'est rle d'une femme d'avoir
des enfant
je trouve qu'elle gâche une grosse
partie de son existence et la chose la
plus importante de sa tâche dans sa vie
c'est une erreur pourquoi parce que la
vie est une chaîne je pense que c'est et
que un certain âge ça leur manquera
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est pas une
vraie femme une vraie femme toutes les
femmes sont des vraies femmes dans la
mesure où elles existe non non non c'est
pas une vraie femme sont pas assez
complètes elles sont
pas à mon avis c'est c'est pas c'est pas
bien enfin je crois que c'est il sont
pas heureuses leur manque quelque chose
ou il leur manquera quelque chose pe
être une femme sans avoir d'enfant
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est une
fuite devant les
responsabilités une fuite disons c'est
l'émancipation de la femme tout dépend
de son caractère vous êtes pour ou
contre personnellement je serais plutôt
contre étonné que pour moi c'est un
épanouissement de la femme de d'avoir un
enfant quit à être mère célibataire
c'est un épanouissement nécessaire
[Musique]
quasiment indispensable vous vous
trouvez face à une femme qui vous dit
qu'elle ne veut pas avoir
d'enfant si elle trouve un homme qui ve
accepter ça c'est parfait je crois que
si la population
ve je pas aprs ça ça va finir il y aura
plus de il y aura plus de comment dire
de population ça la fin du monde un peu
c'est très bien parce qu'il y a beaucoup
du monde ce moment pas suffisant pour au
20e siècle les femmesu vivre li sans
avoir d'enfants les femmes qui ne
veulent pas d'enfants ont un réflexe
égoïste si toutes font de la même façon
la chaîne de la vie va s'interrompre ça
sera la la dépopulation la dénatalité et
bientôt il n'y aura plus personne à la
surface de la Terre l'objection tient de
bout qu'est-ce que vous pouvez répondre
ben il y a deux choses à répondre
d'abord c'est que on ni à une femme une
réalisation propre c'est pour ça qu'on
l'a dit égoïste elle elle n'est reconnue
que si elle se prolonge donc elle n'est
pas pour ce qu'elle est elle-même mais
pour ce qu'elle donne n'est-ce pas comme
un arbre qui porte des fruits donc on on
n son existence ù ça réalisation
personnelle puisque on attend qu'elle se
prolonge vous voulez dire que l'enfant
est un obstacle à sa réalisation
personnelle pas du tout je n'ai pas dit
ça mais je veux dire que dans la société
elle n'est rien si elle n'a pas d'enfant
c'est à l'inverse autrement dit elle r
consqu dit il faut pas qu'elle ait
d'enfant ah non non la conséquence à
attirer est personnelle individuelle
chacune en tire les conséquences qu'elle
qu'elle approuve elle-même bon c'est une
première remarque ça montre bien à quel
point la femme n'est rien dans cette
société puisqu'elle n'est que si elle se
prolonge deuxièmement l'objection de
démographique qui est stupide parce
qu'actuellement le péril qui menace
l'humanité c'est trop de monde et pas
assez si en France nous qui sommes
évolués nous acceptons que la femme
n'est pas d'enfant attention parce que
justement le péril démographique viendra
de l'Extrême Orient où il y a des des
des des peup qui se compent par
centaines de millions et nous seront
submergé de toute façon je crois que
nous ne sommes pas à la veille du jour
où toutes les femmes ensemble vont
décider de ne pas avoir d'enfants c'est
ridicule on est en train de réclamer le
choix de ne pas en avoir jusqu'ici ça a
toujours été en avoir
alors quelquesunes qui n'en ont pas je
voudrais bien qu'on ne les culpabilise
pas qu'on n fasse
pas qu'on nous dit souvent pas du tout
la femme qui n'a pas connu la maternité
n'est pas une femme accomplie
sous-entendu mentalement et
physiologiquement alors est-ce qu'on
peut vous poser la question vous en
penser normalement la maternité pour moi
est le complément normal de la vie du
couple oui mais est-ce que ça veut dire
qu'il manque quelque chose à la femme
qui n'a pas d'enf ah bah c'est elle
qu'il disent on verra bien si manque
quelque chose pensez-vous alors je vous
répondrai par ceci par des arguments
purement médicaux euh il est certain
qu'une femme qui ne veut pas d'enfant
c'est pas tellement fréquent que ça
beaucoup n'en veulent pas immédiatement
et s'assure toujours et c'est ça qui est
frappant que lorsqu'on leur donnera une
contraception elles ne seront pas gêné
lorsqu'elles voudront un enfant ce qui
prouve que le désir de maternité reste
très vivace très profond et paraît dans
la nature deuxièmement point de vue
physiologique il est certain que la
nature est faite de telle façon que ma
fois chaque mois il pourrait y avoir une
fécondation par conséquent c'est déjà
une déédication une femme qui n'a pas
d'enfant a-t-elle quelque chose en moins
c'est-à-dire est-ce que la femme qui est
mère a des transformations physiologique
ou hormonal qui en font vraiment
quelqu'un de différent ou est-ce que
toutes les deux sont sur le plan
hormonal non mais sur le plan
psychologique peut-être moi je le crois
je respecte parfaitement toutes vos
idées il n pas de question mais je crois
qu'il vaut faire une très grosse
différence entre celle qui ne veut pas
avoir d'enfant et celle qui ne peut pas
avoir d'enfant oui sûr justement pour
malheureuse C qui pas en le disant
qu'elles sont it et je dois vous dire
que moi qui m'occupe en tant que
gynécologue de couple stéril ce sont des
femmes et des hmes mais surtout des
femmes que l'on ferait passer par un
trou de cirure à tel point qu'il faut
être souvent très honnête pour ne pas
leur imposer des examens ou des
interventions qui ne soient pas justifié
elle ferait n'importe quoi elle vous
donner un pont d'or elles ferit
n'importe quoi car elles ont ça dans le
S la vocation d'un être humain c'est de
choisir sa vie et son destin et quand
elle l' choisie elle est heureuse elle
est en puisque vous dites ça an je vais
demander je vais demander àon
d'intervenir on dit d'accord on peut
choisir mais si on refuse l'enfant il
faut refuser aussi tout il faut refuser
aussi l'amour mais c'est un tout à fait
différ absolument i madame parce que
l'enfant fait partie de l'amour si vous
prenez l'amour sans l'enfant vous avez
un amour de seconde zone et de dernière
qualité de quoi parlez-v Mame très
certainement mais mettez-vous un peu à
la place de ces malheureux maris estce
alors que leurs femmes leur refusent
leur
refusent ref pas refuse de satisfaire
leur instinct de paternité comment
voulez-vous qu' comp puissent continuer
à aimer leurs femmes et est-ce que ce
sont des femmes qui sont incomplètes ou
qui ont ah ce sont sûrement des femmes
perturbées que de femmes sont ravagés
par des grossesses répétées et
physiquement délabré ça il faut le dire
avec honnê oui qu'est-ce que vous pensez
quand même de de la remarque du
professeur Jamin qui dit queune femme
qui ne veut pas d'enfant est une femme
perturbée vous vous sentez perturbée
mais absolument pas je me sens d'autant
moins perturbée que j'ai choisi je dois
pas être indiscret mais quand même
est-ce que vous n'avez pas eu
l'impression dans votre entourage que
vous avez été rejeté misise au banc un
petit peu à quelqu'un d'aart ça c'est
certain surtout justement vu mon âge
parce que je ne suis pas loin derrière
madame et à l'époque c'était vraiment
quelque chose d'extraordinaire que de
vouloir être une femme sans être une
mère et pour reprendre les mêmes
arguments il y a plus de femmes que
d'hommes il y a plus de ceci est de cela
et je suis aussi d'accord avec Madame
c'est justement ce que je réclame c'est
que ça puisse être un choix et pas une
étiquette la merère et laissez-nous
toutes chacune autant que nous sommes
être un individu qui choisit madame je
suis tout à fait de votre avis et je
pense que cette image de la femme qui
est abord essentiellement mère est
excessivement mauvaise parce que les
femmes peut-être pas les jeunes femmes
de maintenant mais les femmes de notre
âge parce que je suis de votre âge aussi
les femmes de notre âge ont été élevé
presque exclusivement dans cette idée tu
te marieras tu auras des enfants il y
avait pas de choix et c'est ce choix
justement que que les femmes veulent
elles en font ce qu'elles en veulent
après elles en ont elles en ont elles en
ont trois elles en ont quatre elles en
ont un comme elles veulent mais c'est ce
choix et c'est justement cette image
qu'il faut changer et et c'est
excessivement dur pour une femme qui n'a
pas voulu ou qui n'a pas pu avoir
d'enfant de s'imposer en tant que femme
justement qui est différente des
[Musique]
autres